und abgesprochen sind wir alle bei der
zeitenwende auch sie haben sie haben es
richtig formuliert meine these ist dass
uns die zeitenwende in der außenpolitik
wir haben gerade darüber gesprochen auch
alle in eine
politische realität in deutschland
zwingt wir können das durch alle
politikfelder
durchdeklinieren das ist teilweise hier
schon passiert wenn wir uns die
herausforderungen angucken vor denen wir
stehen müssen wir zunächst erstmal uns
ehrlich machen und festhalten dass der
staat nicht unendlich mittel hat die
ressourcen des staates sind endlich wir
haben in der korona pandemie 350
milliarden euro schulden aufgenommen wir
nehmen jetzt für die bundeswehr in einem
sondervermögen nochmal 100 milliarden
auf wir versuchen die ökologische und
digitale transformation mit 200
milliarden euro sondervermögen
anzuschieben wir haben eine generation
leistungsfähiger haben einen score ohne
habe ein ergebnis haben sie davor
aufgemacht
wo entscheiden wir haben heute bei uns
und wir müssen uns ehrlich machen nicht
jetzt in den nächsten wochen aber bei
den haushaltsberatungen 20 23 dass wir
zurückkommen müssen zu stabilen finanzen
zur schuldenbremse dass der staat
ausgaben priorisieren muss das steht
auch im koalitionsvertrag drin und ich
glaube das ist ein stück weit eine
politische realität die alle akteure
auch in der ampel so akzeptieren müssen
und anwenden müssen und wenn wir uns die
inflation in deutschland angucken wenn
die uns angucken was jetzt die koalition
entlastungspaket 1 1 und 2 auf den weg
gebracht hat dann müssen wir auch
festhalten dass wir wohlstandsverluste
hinnehmen werden aufgrund der aktuellen
situation dass wir hier nicht alle
wohlstandsverluste als staat auffangen
müssen und dann ist das die these die
natürlich hier wieder glaube ich zum
konsens führt dass wir uns darauf
zurückbesinnen müssen was dieses land
stark gemacht hat das ist eine moderne
verwaltung das ist aber vor allem auch
unternehmergeist dass es die soziale
marktwirtschaft wir müssen uns darauf
besinnen dass der pioniergeist wieder
fördern müssen dass wir wieder in
technik und forschung verstärkt
investieren müssen und wir müssen uns
auch ehrlich machen auch das gehört zur
zeitenwende dazu dass wenn wir uns
unabhängig machen wollen zb von
russischen gas und russischen öl stärke
auch gucken müssen was wir in
deutschland an ressourcen haben dann
müssen wir darüber nachdenken was für
eine nordsee an gasvorkommen haben was
gegebenenfalls die freundinnen wie lange
noch an ressourcen haben und wir müssen
auch zum beispiel über fracking reden
wenn wir darüber diskutieren dass wir
fracking gas aus den vereinigten staaten
über flüssiggas nach deutschland bringen
dann glaube ich ist es allemal
umweltfreundlicher wenn wir einen teil
auch hier in deutschland wohl ziehen und
so können wir es durch all die
bereiche durchgehen wenn wir uns
landwirtschaft angucken vorrangflächen
für
die jetzt von dem
landwirtschaftsminister zwar für nutzt
ihr futter
freigegeben wurden aber ich glaube das
reicht nicht wenn wir uns auf der
anderen seite angucken was in der
ukraine auch in russland wegfällt das
sind alles themen die jetzt eine
realpolitische wende so hoffen wir es
nach der zeitenwende außenpolitik
bedingungen herr heilmann bedeutet zeit
und wenn wir also eigentlich armut
wohlstandsverluste klingt ja eigentlich
so positiv beladen ich denke also dass
das ist wohlstandsverluste was er sagt
und das müssen wir uns eingestehen aber
sein finanzminister von der fdp hat die
größte rentenerhöhung der letzten zehn
jahre gerade genehmigt die
[Gelächter]
reden über ehrlich nach einer klage an
das was ihre fraktion in den
haushaltsberatungen alles gefordert hat
an mehrausgaben man aufwüchsen sie wäre
das dann tun sie das angefangen also wer
ist mir ja genau richtig aber sie wären
die ersten gewesen die geschrien hätten
wenn wir was die rentenerhöhung angeht
die ja nun auch letztlich nur in der
statistische ist ein statistisches
nachvollziehen ist hier gekürzt hätten
deswegen sie waren diejenigen die am
lautesten geschrien haben als wir die
energie preissenkungen die wir jetzt
vereinbart haben dass die in einem
bereich nicht auch für rentner gelten
das heißt auch wenn wir uns ehrlich
machen wollen dann müssen sie auch sagen
dass sie momentan in der situation sind
als union sie persönlich das hatten wir
eben schon dass sie versuchen die
letzten 16 jahre so ein bisschen
ungeschehen zu machen und zu sagen aber
sie tragen
wir haben recht wir müssen jetzt haben
sie wieder einhalten dafür bin ich
trotzdem für transparente und ehrliche
haushalte und nicht eine sonderform
sonntag wissen das wäre einmal hat mich
ja einen kurzfristigen anderes aber
ansonsten ist ein sondervermögen ja eine
nette umschreibung für umgehung der
schuldenbremse aber die reise doch
angeführt
von der linken seite in der korona er
sollte selbstverständlich in der korona
zeit ausgegeben werden und dann haben
wir gott sei dank gar nicht ganz
gebraucht und dann war unsere idee da
geht er zurück in haushalt und sie sagen
dass die idee ist doch wir geben geld
später aus wenn wir die schuldenbremse
haben denn man ist so gestrickt und das
schöne ist ja herr linden es gibt ja das
schöne zitat von blinder in der talkshow
ruhig weil sie so einen trick würde er
ganz schmutzig das hat er doch vor acht
wochen gesagt jetzt hat er ihn selber
also
mache ich ehrlich ich finde aber ehrlich
gesagt ich würde das gerne so stehen das
ist ja aber ich würde bitten dass sie
uns beide in drei jahren in der
legislatur würde gern einlagen und mir
das spiel wir sehen als nichts davon
eingenommen
ja ich überlege die ganze zeit wie ich
jetzt privat an so ein sondervermögen
was mich auskömmlich freistellt kein
schufa-eintrag macht und nicht schulden
genannt wird das würde ich ganz gerne
auch noch mal für die private
lebensführung einführen aber im ernst
was ich jetzt schmerzlich vermisst habe
war irgendwo das wort sparen also der
normale bürger weiß ja wenn er noch mal
irgendwie eine sonder geschichte hat
auto kaputtgefahren haben was misst muss
ich irgendwo anders kürzen dass wir
jetzt nicht so richtig stattdessen ist
irgendwie die methode der union ja doch
weitergeführt worden wir versuchen alles
mit geld so weit zuzuschütten damit es
nicht wehtut und das verstehe ich zwar
man wird ja nicht als regierung sprachen
habe ich kann sagen dass dies kein
bisschen glück hier und da aber wir
haben die schuldenbremse ist sechs jahre
lang kein gehalt wir haben ein bisschen
glück gab es gar nicht
wir haben eingehalten hieß ihnen
geschieht aber das kann sich ganz auf
die sogenannte das nicht gibt haben
gesagt wir müssen ab dem jahr 2023 die
haushaltsberatung beginnen jetzt im
sommer dazu die schuldenbremse einhalten
und die nettokreditaufnahme die wir von
der vorgängerregierung übernommen haben
im haushaltsentwurf jetzt sind fast 100
milliarden euro das heißt dass wir 90
milliarden euro von diesem ansatz runter
müssen das heißt dass wir sehr wohl
darüber reden müssen dass in einzelnen
etats gespart werden muss das habe ich
gesagt mit priorisieren und
konsolidieren deswegen glaube ich schon
dass wir uns in den nächsten jahren hier
dergestalt ehrlich machen müssen dass
wir nicht werden sie sparen bis es
quietscht
das war glaube ich ein stück weit ihr
koalitionspartner auf landesebene der
das formuliert hat aber
da gehört es doch zur ehrlichkeit dazu
können wir die schuldenbremse haben dann
heißt das dass wir die ausgaben linie
damit halten und auf der anderen seite
auch das gilt auch für jeden anderen
haushalt werden die haushalte über eine
einnahme linie konsolidiert werden das
heißt wir müssen wirtschaftswachstum
generieren wir müssen alles habe ich in
der schönen bremsen gegangen sondern
wieder werden wir aber die schulden aber
wir werden die schuldenbremse im
nächsten jahr einhalten wenn politiker
sagen wir müssen und wir brauchen nicht
skeptisch das heißt nicht wir tun und
wir werden aber ist egal wer nur ich sie
haben ja jetzt schon als die steigenden
energiepreise waren dann versucht das
ganze irgendwie unten so abzumildern und
gleichzeitig steht ja auch im
koalitionsvertrag dass energie
sukzessive verteuert werden soll um den
lästigen bürger solche marotten wie
autofahren und sowas möglichst zu
verleihen aber da muss ich aber die
armen verteilen
aber kann man so nicht stehen
die energie soll gewollt verteuert
werden da können sie jetzt unmöglich
hinter ja immerhin gehen dann können das
wieder runter subventionieren damit und
natürlich mir jedoch auch nicht immer
sondern wir reden darüber dass haben
haben wir haben wir haben jetzt eine
verteuerung bei konsumgütern bei
lebensmitteln und so weiter das wären
sie irgendwie auffangen müssen im
unteren bereich des einkommens und da
bin ich sehr gespannt drauf da wird man
irgendetwas streichen müssen fürchte ich
einfach man kann nicht gleichzeitig
beispielsweise in der landwirtschaft auf
ökologische wirtschaft umsteigen die
felder möglichst weitgehend mit paneelen
zu stellen und gleichzeitig dann
überhaupt dass die preise aber dass man
gerade meine these dass wir genau hier
in der tat die zeitenwende auch in die
innenpolitik kriegen
wir das mit halten werden jetzt soll es
wohl denn dann treffen wir uns nochmal
gucken überhaupt ansatzweise an möchten
wir jetzt nicht nur über die zeitenwende
die großen
natürlich auch die frage an sie welcher
vor herausforderungen stehen in uns
bürgern bevor so mittelbar und wie
werden die nächsten jahre das größte ist
die inflation glaube ich das wird jetzt
auch noch länger so bleiben und ich sehe
da jetzt ich meine es ist ja zum teil
ezb getrieben jetzt ist es zum
europäischen zentralbank für die
zuschauer das ist jetzt zum teil corona
getrieben jetzt haben wir schlittern wir
in die nächste krise reihen den
richtigen krieg aber das ist schon eine
antwort die die man da geben muss und
ich glaube da wird auch ideologische
bruchstellen geben zwischen fdp und
grünen zum beispiel und der spd was man
da wo man will man geld geben will wem
nicht wo man was kappen muss und
dergleichen bisher hat die ampel ist
mein eindruck ja
ideologische differenzen mit geld
zugeschüttet
ja man hat sich irgendwie geeinigt hat
er einfach geld drauf geschmissen hat
dann schon gepasst das wird in zukunft
ja nicht so gehen auf dauer habe ich und
wenn man das dann im bundle haben wir
nicht gemacht jetzt bitte die
impfpflicht kann man nicht durchgeht ist
dann kann man sich ja einiges eigentlich
man sich von landet man seine entwickelt
und dann wird man da ideologische brüche
sehen und dann wird es auch mal richtig
rum ssten in der ampel ich meine das ist
jetzt sind äußere faktoren die die
reihen schließen das wird so auf dauer
nicht weitergehen man hat es ja
wunderbar gesehen es gibt ja nicht mal
eine mehrheit es gibt auch keine für die
für die impfpflicht habe jetzt keine
mehrheit für sozusagen das
sondervermögen bundeswehr die 100
milliarden da wir die fcb die spd jetzt
schon zurück rudern das wird alles sehr
spannend also dass dass die spd beim
sondervermögen zurück ich glaube ich
nicht da wäre momentan die frage ob die
union nachdem sie die letzten 16 jahre
bei der bundeswehr so gewirtschaftet wie
sie gewirtschaftet hat die
verfassungsändernde mehrheit wir
brauchen zwei drittel um das grundgesetz
zu ändern
das war kein vorsitzender alles
formuliert da gewinnt man eher den
eindruck dass die union versucht aus
genau dieser öffentlichen zusage
herauszukommen wir werden ja sehen dass
werden wir nächsten zwei monaten sehen
ob die union bei dem sondervermögen
zustimmt oder nicht um die bundeswehr
hier zu ertüchtigen das ist ihnen ein
wichtiger das land oder die eigene
partei das land dann lassen sie uns doch
jetzt mehr in den letzten jahren über
das land sprechen und vor welchen
herausforderungen aber ich werde ich
werde ja immer gefragt die fdp hat
natürlich genau verdienen also dass die
wichtigste herausforderung ist doch
genau die dass wir feststellen müssen
dieses land hat in den letzten jahren
über seine verhältnisse gelebt seit
corona haben wir ganz ganz viele
schulden aufgenommen wir sehen das in
diesem land ganz ganz viel nicht
funktioniert und das sind die
herausforderungen die wir angehen müssen
und das werden wir nur dadurch schaffen
dass wir auf der einen seite
wirtschaftskraft in diesem land halten
deswegen können wir auch nicht so
kurzfristig und so schnell aus den
fossilen energieträgern aussteigen wie
das vielleicht einige andere wollen und
auf der anderen seite dass die
unternehmer tun dass wir die
grundschülerin müssen dass wir die
grundlagen
unserer gesellschaft
erneuern wir haben im wahlprogramm von
neugründung gesprochen das ist das was
jetzt in den nächsten monaten ansteht
dass wir uns darauf zurückbesinnen
zurückziehen und dann auch die
diskussion in der ampel natürlich für
und ich glaube dass es unbedingt
notwendig nach den letzten monaten was
jetzt außenpolitischen auf uns
zugekommen ist klickt man sehr schön
bemühens zusage und abgerechnet wird am
schluss abgerechnet wird dann in
dreieinhalb jahren kann man dann sagen
ein bläulich übrigen auch versprochen
noch mal einladen aber dann nicht
nebeneinander setzen ich glaube ich
werde sie auseinander setzen wir noch
weniger
nämlich gut aber die letzte frage ist es
ihre these heimat sie dürfen damit dann
auch die diskussion abrunden und beenden
wenn sie noch ein wunsch oder zwei
wünsche äußern wollen was ihnen jetzt
als politiker das wichtigste anliegen
wäre wenn sie heute kanzler werden oder
ist natürlich das wichtigste anliegen
wäre das für die ukraine so unterstützen
dass ein krieg gewinnen weil das
sozusagen ja für die ukraine absolut
lebenswichtig ist aber natürlich für den
ganzen westen aber wenn sie jetzt
innenpolitische karrierefragen dann
würde ich mir wünschen dass ihr
verfahrensbeschleunigung machen aber
nicht nur für windräder und solarparks
denn wenn wir die ganze wirtschaft
transformieren das ist geht ja schon für
den elektro sir also für denjenigen der
erneuerbaren strom wasserstoff macht
geht jetzt die fans beschleunigung nicht
für die netze gilt es dann so nicht und
tesla dann schon gleich gar nicht wir
brauchen eine verfahrensbeschleunigung
für alles und meine hoffnung wäre dass
die regierung sich dazu wäre es nicht
jetzt durchringen denn dafür hätte sie
theoretisch die beschlüsse in einem
koalitionsvertrag und dann werden alle
größere wunder dass wir als partei
ergreifen mal aufmachen und wirklich
diesen staat von grund auf neu aufbauen
weil wir werden so nicht weiterkommen